hello everybody this is grandmaster
varakobian and welcome to the
insane in the endgame class today and i
have some really hard positions
to show you today i hope you guys are
ready okay
to solve this difficult puzzle so we're
going to start out with the first
position
uh let's see here
white to play and win
these are end game studies so you have
to find
the difficult positions to win
so let's see here
all right let's see here how white can
try to win
this position here
give you a couple of minutes to think to
see if you can
find the idea here
clearly the position of the kink is a
problem
on a4 and you have a f-pass pump so what
can you do
all right all right so let's see here
what options we have in this position
here
and also we have a strong pass pawn so
we have to try to do something with that
past pawn okay
we have to do something with that past
pawn on f7 here
okay
i'll take a look at i'll be looking at
the chat guys
[Music]
so if if you have any questions you can
ask me there
okay another minute or two another
minute and two minutes or two and now
let's see here
insane in the end game
all right okay so that's the first
position guys
so we have to look you have to look for
ways to
uh i mean either made or promote the
pawn right
so those are the two options we have to
do here
any ideas any ideas you have here
the first move is pretty clear we have
to try to
promote we have to try to promote that's
the only way we can try to win this
position okay
so the first first idea is try to
promote
okay so f7
correct
now um you're also threatening to play
rook
a rook a check and then f8 promotion so
he has to go here
queen e5
now he goes queen if i'm now treating
some queen a1 ideas as well here
yeah i got queen a1 idea so what to do
now we have to try to figure out so
check is the next move we have to go
correct
now he goes king b3 and now if we queen
unfortunately we're gonna get made it
we're gonna get mated with this
so the first move is fine and now right
here right here now we need a very
special move here
all right now let's see here all right
now i can see the chart here so
summer rook a3 rk3 and
promotion okay rook a3 that's correct
but the line just keeps going it's this
is it's not over yet
so he takes
now we promote now he goes
here and he's still threatening the
numerous threats he's threatening
queen a1 and he's threatening queen b2
so what are you going to do here now
what are you going to do against that
right now
because it looks like he still has
threats i mean you have a threat
check there on b8 he'll take if you
check here he'll go here
so now you need an amazing move amazing
idea
queen b4 correct absolutely brilliant
move
if he doesn't take us here it's mate
so he has to take the first check
king b5 take king c5
now you still have to show accuracy to
win this it's not so simple okay
because he still has three pawns so if
you don't play accurately you're not
gonna win this game
so what is the correct move now
king d2 correct d5
d4
so
um
now we gotta take now he goes here
our move is only move and now he goes
here it looks like how are we gonna win
this game guys it looks like
you know he can just play c4 and then
sit there you know
but you can win this by one tempo okay
only by one tempo you can win this if it
was blocked to move he plays c4 it's
going to be a draw now
okay so what are you going to do
and now what to do here stink you have
to play this correctly otherwise you're
not going to win this game
go here now you're here
now if he goes here you have bishop e1
stopping the pawns
if he goes here again you play bishop e1
now if you play c2 you have bishop d2
here's this
if he plays d3 we take if he goes here
we just go king to e4
here push here and now what's the
correct move
if you go c2 you play bishop d2 and now
it's a win
and if he goes here you're gonna take
take
and take okay
all right guys amazing study amazing
study again we have to play this way
not this because we get made a rook a3
check
and this is not good either so you have
to play the move queen before
absolutely stunning correct
good job good job guys very very nice
alright ready for the next one now
good job
all right why to play
and win
why to play and win guys
why to play and win
now i'm using uh
i'm using uh the leachates hs uh
website
so what can you do here to try to win
this position
hey greetings greetings friends from
bosnia how how are you
how are you how are you
thank you thank you thank you
so we have to calculate we have to
calculate guys here
it's it's just if you just try to play a
simple way it's not going to do it okay
so c7 it just goes bishop b7
it's gonna be a problem
hmm
there should be one that's correct
now he has to go king f6 okay
by the way if you play c7 he plays
bishop b7 as a draw
now a very very important move here
needed okay
bishop e4 absolutely
and now we're threatening c7 okay
but he's not gonna make it that simple
for you he's gonna come here and attack
you
and now it's very tricky
you have to really dig in deep you know
you have to really dig in deep to find
the solution okay
c5 is a draw because he takes
check okay
let's draw
you have to calculate basically you have
to calculate every single move with the
bishop
you can go to d5 you can go to f3 you
can go to g2 you can go to h1 you have
to calculate all of them
and after you calculate you can make a
decision
ugh
the correct move here is bishop
h1 correct because everywhere else you
put it's going to be on the way but not
in here
now you're threatening c7 so he goes
here
trying to catch the pawn then c7 if he
takes
you're going to promote into queen
yeah c7
c7 and then you take and if it takes
you go here okay perfect
all right let's set up the next one guys
so yeah he cannot do anything after this
can't do anything can't go anywhere so
after bishop you win the game
okay very hard move to see bishop we're
looking at all the other moves but not
the one
on each one all right next
good job guys that maneuver was very
nice
okay white to play
and win
right to play and win i want to give you
a couple of minutes to think
okay
couple of minutes to think
um
uh
white to play and win
white to play and win
how are you gonna try to win this
position because the problem here is
is the steel mate issue okay
the problem is the steel mate issue here
okay
all right
so what can we do here this threat is a
real problem here guys
why to play and win of course
the problem our knight is too far off if
when our knight was close
we can try to meet him but it's the
knight is too far off
and it's very hard for him to reach f2
you know
now what can we do
all right what's the first one bishop g3
that is correct
uh actually not that sorry first we have
to force
first we have to force f to h2 so it
goes here
then what we do
that's a very tricky plan to do here
yeah well if you take the pesh gas the
pawns you're gonna win with bishop and
knight if you know how to do it if you
watch my video tutorial on that
you'll know how to do it if you watch my
video tutorial
okay
but what's the movement bishop g3 plays
h4
correct now it's a very important move
here
if you take it's a still mate so it's
very very important to play precisely
here
so what do we do now guys after h4 what
do we do now
it's a very special move you have to
find
no bishop h2 is just draw q ticks
bishop
yeah but that's that's just going to be
a draw in that line
yeah bishop f4 it will be a draw
bishop b8 okay
now he goes here
kj3
kg1
now you want to push him back to the
corner correct if he moves away
you take you're going to win this
so he has to go back here
and now finally we have a time now to
bring the knight
in knight b6
now
bring the knight where where is the
knight going now
with the same concept you want to win
the h2 pawn okay
with the same concept you want to win
the h2 pawn
knight c4 check
perfect
now if you take it still mate no no no
you're not gonna let that happen guys no
no no
okay what are you going to do
yes bishop f8 yes
thank you very much and again guys
you're gonna have to know how to win
this position okay
but this is winning position you can
watch my video or some other videos as
well
of tutorials how to win this okay
absolutely amazing
you know your night your night had to be
moved like this
to get to here and you had to avoid the
steel maze okay
you had to avoid the steel mates alright
guys
excellent
okay next position here why
to play and win
okay white to play and win
this pawn is going this way by the way
it's one move away from queening okay
yeah it's a tricky one that's a tricky
one
yeah but it was i liked the way that it
was the maneuvering i really like the
maneuvering
why to play and win this one
okay when the first move is clear we
have to give a check now it's no choice
we have to give a check
first idea is clear okay rook h6 check
now uh
yeah if if you play like knight d8 check
he just goes
king b5 it's just a draw all right now
he goes here
yeah if if you try this it's just not
going to work
yeah and then it basically went like
this
okay so that's that wins that takes care
of it okay
so it has to go here to control the a6
square okay
knight now we have to play precisely
okay
96 check you know here and then i quinn
so you might you know
that throws away the win pay attention
guys pay attention
you know it's not like you see a check
you got to go for it you have to make
sure that's the correct
correct check okay 98 correct peter
98 check now he has to go here otherwise
okay six
yeah i remember this one yeah i saw this
one before but just
just forgot it
knight c6 check correct
yeah now if he goes to b7 you have a
check and check so here you have knight
before
it has to go here
and now you have to come up with a very
strong move here
because it doesn't look like you can
stop him i mean yeah you can take this
guy
he queens you can do this
that'll be a draw
now very important idea here
knight so what's the move
no night before he wins
yeah knight a5 now you're threatening
knight b3 so i have to queen
now we check if he goes to b7 i take
and now check thank you very much
winning the queen and winning the pawn
of course
okay so absolutely fantastic idea i mean
it's just
it's a hard puzzle it's a hard puzzle
hard study to you have to come up with
this
knight a5 clever touch you know
clever touch to set him up with okay
very clever stuff okay
right perfect guys moving forward okay
good job
all right white to play
why to play and win
this is not that hard guys this is not
that hard
but i don't want you to give me one
moves okay i don't take one moose i need
the whole variation okay
don't give me one more lines now give me
a five six move line okay
the whole the whole thing is about six
moves
so yeah don't give one move guys just
try to give the whole variation okay
because you do
move by move it's going to be easy
so
so
[Music]
so who can give me the whole variation
here
the whole variation okay
okay i see a couple of moves but they're
very short they're like three more
variations okay
all right
arya on that line rook h7 your rook is
still on c5 you cannot go to k7
hello hello petai petai hello
what is this i'm a true attacker what is
this
all right so we start out we start out
with what
i still don't see the complete answer i
would like to see somebody give me the
complete answer here
rook a4 okay that's correct
now what do you do
check
check k so this is forcing okay
now what do we do
rook h7 yes fantastic
because now if he takes check
check and you pick up the queen okay
so rook h7
here goes queen g2
check
thank you very much okay
so um and if he plays g2
because if you take his g1 queen in fact
you lose the game
you're gonna lose the game because it's
gonna check and take
now what are you going to do after this
oh no not can get ps queen f5 check
what's the move here guys
yes
and then you win the game beautiful
beautiful guys excellent
excellent excellent job guys these are
strong puzzles but we got some really
strong players in the chat here
you know you guys doing an amazing job
solving these difficult positions okay
it was perfect
alright guys and now this one
white to play and win again i don't want
you to
give me some moves i need you to give me
the whole thing okay
white to play and win this is a study by
a famous composer
leonid kobel leonid kubel
okay
actually not that hard i think you're
going to be able to find this guys
you have to play like leonid kobel
all right guys let's see here
these are special exercises from a very
special book
it's a russian book that i get with it's
very very special stuff here
please think please think guys this is
not a
this is not an easy position for you to
do
bishop d6 is a droid plays rook c8
bishop d6 replace rook c8
so
three
okay now let's see here
the first move what is the first move
guys here
no not bishop h6
all right the first move first move is
very important here
bishop c5 correct
now you're threatening check on h8 okay
so if he plays rook b8 then how do you
win this
why is this move losing
and here okay
winning so
rook c8
check king e8
yeah we're gonna look at king c8 next
don't don't worry about that we can look
let's do this first
bishop c7 correct now he can't move the
rook
on eight you have rook h8 check he
cannot move to fade you have checked so
he has to push
now what do we do
here right
now we walk all the way here now he
takes if you take
he's gonna escape and then it's gonna be
uh
it's gonna be a draw check and
it's theoretical draw but here you can
make a move here to put him in a
suksalang yes
yes ariana yes and that's a suksavang
suk sawangi okay if the king goes here
you have a check and take
if he goes here you have a check and
take
if he takes on c7 looks sad so you're
winning the game
got it perfect
nice
now
now somebody mentioned
uh what if he plays
what if he plays let's say the move
here
okay
sorry this is the this story yeah so we
play bishop c5
well let's say he plays here okay
and now what is the correct move here
guys
no no no no don't rush don't rush
yes bishop a7 correct
now he cannot go here because we have a
check
so his only move is to push
in this case it doesn't matter you can
even take because the rook is not coming
out anywhere
okay it's not in a box here
check and take okay
so you're winning this game all right
well i think this is a pretty remarkable
pretty remarkable idea guys that you
just
you basically chop the rook in both
cases to win the game okay
all right guys i hope you enjoyed this
puzzles
from the end game insane and endgame
puzzle class
and i will be back with you on thursday
okay
for two more uh for two more lectures on
thursday okay
and make sure you tune in for those
lectures
and those lectures going to be starting
a little bit earlier
so put it in your calendar guys
uh those those lectures on thursday okay
going to be starting at 4 to 6 p.m
thursday this thursday 4 to 6 p.m
all right guys all right very good
thank you everybody for watching and uh
i will be seeing you again on thursday
okay
take care bye bye everybody good job
good job
you